Pearl was born sometime around 1898 give
or take a couple years in rural Texas as
the only child of first generation of
German immigrants she was raised on a
farm with a strict Protestant upbringing
her parents prayed before every meal and
disciplined Pearl harshly when she
stepped out of line This continued well
into Pearl's adulthood Pearl's childhood
was presumably quite lonely there's no
mention of siblings cousins or friends
of any kind in Pearl's life Pearl's
imagination was a refuge for her growing
up she imagined a life for herself
outside the farm and she became obsessed
with that dream there was also a darker
side to Pearl her mother mentions
terrible things that she seen her do in
private presumably to the farm animals
Pearl even admits to this herself Pearl
dreamed of a life outside the farm but
that dream was always just Out Of Reach